[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to the
GameSpot stage I'm Mike McCarty here
with Lucy James hello
and this is pretty much gonna be her
interview because I'm gonna be talking
about Kingdom Hearts 3 and we are lucky
enough to be talking to I'm Brendan
Doherty from sporanox
thank you so much for joining us on the
stage and Kingdom Hearts 3 got caught a
few times during the press conference
Microsoft Square zone press conference
and Sony so tell us about what we saw
this year before we dive deeper into
Kingdom Hearts 3 yeah no it was a very
exciting e3 for us we actually started
before hand with the Kingdom Hearts
world tour Orchestra in Los Angeles
where we revealed the release date
January 29th 2019 on Xbox one and
PlayStation 4 and then from there it was
just great because we yeah we got to
reveal frozen at the Microsoft
conference that the frozen is joining
the Kingdom Hearts universe and then as
well as Pirates of the Caribbean at the
Sony one yeah and there's just a lot of
secrets and it just felt really good to
get them all out there and have all the
fans positively react and and see all
the love including from you guys we got
a so thank you very much for that cut
off like naval combat right maybe I'm
sorry naval combat yep big switch-up
especially so we've seen the parts of
the Korean world know Muslims to be in
Kingdom Hearts 2 what's gonna be the
huge changes I mean not only just for
how it looks but like some of the
gameplay changes we can expect from that
world sure first and foremost you know
looks beautiful photorealistic fantastic
with that I always geek out about the
textures and the clothing cuz that's
nothing like the more sounds really good
with like fashion and all that and just
everyone's clothing and especially Sora
Donald and Goofy spirit costumes are
just so detailed and just so impressive
like I'm always kind of finding new
things to look at
but yeah so in the pirates world we
showed a little bit of like land sea and
air combat where there were the ship
battles Sora does dive underwater on
this one and then it was also battling
the Heartless in the skies as well and
sort of soaring from heartless to
heartless and sort of having a boss
battle in the sky and
and flow motioning on some rainbows so a
lot of stuff to look forward to what's
it like I you know I mean this games
been in development
I was interviewed amorous on yesterday
and you know they were working on this
before Kingdom Hearts 2 it even shipped
and I think by the time it comes out up
in 13 years since then what's it like
actually having actual gameplay out
people getting their hands on it
being able to finally show it off it
feels so gratifying especially because
the Kingdom Hearts fanbase is just so
passionate and positive and you know
that they are invested in the stories
invested in the characters they want to
know what is gonna happen you know with
Sora and Riku and and and Roxas is he
gonna come back and all that stuff so
you know that the hints that Nomura son
leaves from the trailers are ones that
they're smart enough they're gonna pick
up on and talk about and it's just it's
just fun to see that and then in the
office it's fun you know I get to play
the game and see some levels that you
know we haven't shown yet and that's
just a blast and and it just it feels
good as a fan of the series knowing like
okay it's all coming together it's all
gonna deliver and yeah it makes my job a
lot easier I mean speaking of the things
that Nomura son has been putting in the
trailer is like aqua that kind of big
reveal it seems like she's succumbed to
the darkness in some way like the
internet went kind of crazy about that
yeah it does does not look too good for
aqua right now she's been in the the
dark world since birth by Sleep and yeah
we kind of saw hints of that zan or
possession in her eyes yeah so yeah I've
heard on the internet you know aqua got
nor did as a meme I saw going around so
hopefully you know we'll have to have to
learn a little bit more about that so a
lot of people I mean like myself
included you kind of grow up with
Kingdom Hearts with the story the story
is it's one of those things that you
kind of understand it as you're playing
it but trying to explain Kingdom Hearts
to people who might not be familiar and
with Kingdom Hearts 3 is this a good
jumping in point for new players how are
you gonna introduce the themes and
characters to people who might not be
for who would probably be familiar with
the Disney and Pixar aspects of it but
maybe not the story of Kingdom Hearts
yeah and I think it gets a wrap for
having a complex story because there are
a lot of moving pieces and a lot of
characters with
but at the core of it it's just a battle
of light versus darkness and the power
of friendship and the power of friends
doing the right thing you have Sora
who's our Keyblade wielder the main hero
with Donald Duck and Goofy you know
well-known characters traveling from
Disney World to Disney World to protect
those worlds from the Heartless invasion
these shadowy creatures and you know and
I try and tell people how can you March
for the first time like it really that's
what the core of it is the dark versus
light and the friendship like you can
get into all that stuff but it's like
talking to someone about Star Wars like
yeah it's like the good guys versus the
bad guys and you got the force and you
know Darth Vader and all that stuff or
you can go like oh well this is like
wedge antilles is like backstory this is
what he was doing as a teenager and
here's the guy in the cantina I like you
can go that deep if you want to with all
the organization 13 members but really
it's pretty easy it's still Disney it's
pretty easily okay zan ort that guy that
looks pretty evil he's the bad guy
you know the shady guys and the cloaks
kind of shady watch out for them so yeah
it's pretty and then of course the
Disney characters everyone knows they're
their favorite heroes and characters
from that so that makes it pretty easy
yeah what's it like I mean the game has
been in development a very long time
obviously so what's it like having to
juggle Oh I mean frozen wasn't the thing
when you first started Kingdom Hearts 3
I don't think angle is a thing when you
started Kingdom Hearts 3 now they're
both in the game like what's it like
juggling these new properties that are
releasing as you're continuing to build
the game yeah part of it is Disney just
getting bigger throughout since Kingdom
Hearts 2 came out I mean when they they
acquired Pixar back it back a couple
years ago and that was big and and now
that we have Pixar worlds like Toy Story
monsters Inc we showed ratatouille the
fact that they're in the game now that's
a whole another amazing group of
characters and stories to play with and
bring into the franchise so that was
something that you know they wanted to
do right if you're gonna have Pixar in
there and then yeah there's been with
the Disney Animation Studios kind of
since they're their modern era from
tangled onwards it's really it's like a
new golden era kind of like what I had
growing up in the 90s that kind of
recapture that magic and you have titles
like tangled and frozen and big hero six
and and these are ones that you know I
got I'm getting a little bit older so
it's like the younger generation can
have their Disney heroes and they
can be like okay those are the
characters I grew up with and that I
want to play with some dimension briefly
right so to either when we saw it in the
trailer but it wasn't immediately
apparent if it was like a summon is it
an actual full world so he we've shown
him we haven't quite revealed everything
that he's doing but it did look like he
was teaching sora how to cook yeah so
that's a good life skill to pick up I'm
sure it'll be useful on his quest we do
have some other summon characters so
characters who we have can reveal that
summons or links as we call them we've
revealed Ariel The Little Mermaid and
she was like a water elemental attack
where she dives into the the the ground
and kind of crates like water jets
there's wreckit-ralph which is great cuz
he's got a new movie coming out and he
comes out of like a CRT TV and creates
these like blocks that'll kind of trap
people with electricity and then he
smashes them and wrexham one of my
favorites is Kings flare you got the
Lion King you got Simba just on fire
looking like kind of touching like the
efreet from Final Fantasy series and
that's just great you know he's he's
like a comet in the sky that crashes
down has this like fire blaze that spins
around and then also in the trailer we
showed meow which is one of the dream
eaters from dream Drop Distance and and
so he makes reappearance as well
obviously the relationship between
Square Enix and Disney it's been going
on for you know 15 or so years right now
would you say that Disney how are they
to work with you know they're letting
you take their properties and
incorporate them into something new
what's that relationship been like and
what's the state of it today like they
do they have more trust in you than they
did before yeah I mean there's always
been trust because that's how something
like that could happen in the first
place but it's a fantastic partnership
it's something that you know we can't
have all these properties and without
their help and and without Pixar getting
involved and it's something the Pixar
team was excited because in our game
we're creating things that haven't been
seen in the Pixar movies so it's a you
know you would see Andy's bedroom yeah
toy story but now it's like we kind of
have like okay well what's out his
bedroom window what's you know is
backyard look like or what's this like
Street look like so we're filling out
of the architecture of Andy's house that
the the Pixar people haven't seen yet so
they they have fun and seen that happen
and they have fun with like you know the
details like Woody's arm got you know
ripped off in Toy Story 2 and you can
see like that stitching just a subtle
detail to be so easy to miss but they
you know that they're both Pixar and
Nomura sons team are such perfectionist
that there's kind of a mutual respect
yeah and then you know the Disney the
the people that I interact with love the
franchise are the biggest cheerleaders
of it and it's really sad to see them
get excited
we had revealed Toy Story at d23 yeah
last year and actually three years ago
we revealed big hero 6 key art and it's
just fun to have you know the fans there
cheering the Disney executives get all
excited and they love this they
recognize how big this franchise is you
know they're seeing how great it's noon
at e3 and you know they're looking for
ways to make Kingdom Hearts 3 bigger as
well
it's a piggyback off Mike's earlier
question about you know as you're
creating Kingdom Hearts 3 you know the
Pixar and Disney Animation like tangled
they weren't a thing but in the during
the course of Kingdom Hearts threes
development obviously you have the
Disney acquisition of Marvel and of
Lucasfilm so I kind of feel like I have
to ask the question go on we're gonna
see Marvel install it obviously I cannot
answer so sorry
yeah it is something that's that is
something different and I think it's
that we'd probably like to hear what the
fans have to think about that is I think
that Disney worlds make sense yeah Pixar
worlds makes sense Marvel and Star Wars
are is it is a little different layer of
separation no I
you know I think the fans would want to
hear what they have to say about that
time and also I mean like one of the
core tenets of Kingdom Hearts certainly
very much at the beginning was the
inclusion of Final Fantasy characters
and they have kind of been noticeably
absent from the trailers that we've been
seeing it seems like you guys are really
leaning hard into the Disney aspect
what's been the process are you guys
just holding them back
or are we just gonna see less of them
because Kingdom Hearts is now its own
story well this is the conclusion it's
on story of the dark seeker saga like
this is where it's all coming to a head
so
if you seen for the trailers we're it's
definitely a lot of the Kingdom Hearts
characters a lot of the organization 30
members that some of them have been
presumed defeated or deceased and
they're kind of making a comeback so
there's still a lot to cram in here so
we have made any official announcements
yet but the focus really is like what
can we do for the Kingdom Hearts
storyline let's make sure we do that
justice first to be honest just when
haina pensando let turned up like oh
okay finally they're back so we're
seeing right now some of you can see the
Toy Story world oh yeah so this is a
demo that I actually played and what was
kind of refreshing to me is that like
despite it looking current-gen it very
much felt to me like a Kingdom Hearts
game and so when it comes to the
gameplay what are the important things
that you have to bring from old Kingdom
Hearts games but also to modernize for
an audience that might not have played
the old ps2 games yeah so it's a lot
it feels very fluid and action-oriented
it feels like modern gen so if you
haven't played since Kingdom Hearts 2
the story and the series has continued
there's been a lot of hands held titles
where they've kind of experimented with
some elements of gameplay and it's been
nice to be able to see like okay what
works what do we really like what do we
want to bring into it so then we can
have like the definitive version of the
gameplay in the you know the next-gen
console version so some of the things
that are exciting are the Keyblade
evolutions where if you look in the
bottom left corner of the screen you see
those arrows as those level up Sora's
Keyblade is going to get two different
forms and different transformations and
so it's no longer just like a melee
weapon like you know something like a
keyblade okay now it's like a heavy
hammer or now it's a drill claw or in
terms of like the Monsters Inc people as
its final form is a twin yo-yos and so
there's that so there's different key
blades have different attacks also for
the first time in this series players
can equip three different key blades at
once you can start your combo with your
Toy Story attack move onto Monsters Inc
and then like end it with Rapunzel's
like tower summoning the tower and the
Rapunzel Keyblade is kind of like more
magic focus so it rains down magic
attacks the the missile attack system to
attack enemies from afar the shot lock
system returns
and each one of the keyblade's also has
really special shot lock animations
those look beautiful each world has its
own gameplay elements so in Toy Story
you might have gotten to the gigas demos
like it gets max yep and that sort of
yeah Sora jumps into a toy mech at the
toy store and all of a sudden he's kind
of playing a you know first-person
shooter mech game yeah and frozen in the
trailer we showed a little bit of like
downhill downhill action on Goofy's
shield so there's a little bit of like
that like winter sports sort of feel
with that yeah and then the ship battles
well with parts yeah I was gonna say I'm
curious obviously the you've got
combining Disney and Final Fantasy from
a visual aesthetic storytelling
standpoint but from a gameplay
perspective with a game so long a
development are there any specific
outside sources that you're taking
inspiration from aside from the earlier
Kingdom Hearts games or something like
Final Fantasy 15 to speed more recently
well I know that you know the soccer
team are a bunch of avid gamers so I'm
sure they're always looking I probably
couldn't speak personally for them on
that one but I know Anna Morrison has
set a lot of standards in the industry
over the last 20 years you know creator
of Final Fantasy 7 character designer of
many of the iconic Final Fantasies so
it's probably more people probably taken
from him than the other way around
sure given Kingdom Hearts threes you
know it's had a very big presence at
this year's e3 when I mean obviously
recently got delayed like I did hope it
would launch in 2018 but speaking to
numerous on yesterday he was explaining
that it was because they're aiming for
that worldwide release they have to just
make sure all the ducks in a row what
the the announcement of the delay was at
the concert immediately preceding e3 you
know just worrying about the kind of
reasoning behind that like you are on
three different stages what was the
reason behind of not sitting early its
Nomura son appreciates the fans of
Kingdom Hearts so much that he he always
wants to give them something special and
give it to him something first so that
was why at the KH orchestra you know
it's sold out in like two days
there was extra things like he Shimon
Morrison came on stage the the composer
Kingdom Hearts she played one of her
songs she played a Toy Story medley that
hasn't been revealed yet and then the
more son was able to reveal the trailer
and that's the first time people saw
that ratatouille was going to be in saw
the hints of some of the KH characters
what was going to happen with their
storylines and he thought that the core
fans are the ones that deserve to know
the most because they're the ones that
have been invested for over a decade so
long that's him trying to repay the fans
and letting them know like hey I do hear
you I do listen to you and I want to
tell you this first rather than just
sort of like everyone all at once some
of these more bigger conferences right
awesome well Brendan thank you so much
for coming on our e3 stage we really
appreciate you taking the time out thank
you yeah thanks for having me and thanks
for the best of e3 Award for Kingdom
Hearts 3 and yeah hope everyone gets it
in January
yeah yeah and congratulations on being
able to show much more of the game this
year over yeah like we said three
conferences yeah it was all over the
place it's been a good e3 for us yeah
happy well enjoy the rest of the week
and everybody if you've been watching
all week this is mine and Lucy's last
interview friends so thank you we get to
close out with you and if you're
watching we will be back later well
immediately sorry later today we've got
kind of funny coming on we've got a
bunch of different coordinates and kind
of funny guys yeah yeah great lineup and
thank you so much for joining us
throughout the week so stick around
we'll be back as soon as possible
[Music]
you
[Music]